president trump's biggest covid critics
are facing criticisms
of their own new york governor andrew
cuomo under fire for
a slow rollout of vaccines his state has
administered less than a third of the
shots
it has on hand governor cuomo pointing a
finger at hospitals
for the slow delivery and is threatening
to find those facilities
if they don't give out all their doses
quickly enough
and new york city mayor bill de blasio
being called tone deaf
for dancing in an empty time square to
ring in the new year
greg i know you're a big fan of mayor de
blasio let's start with you
um thoughts on that he is
such an awful human being that i can't
even think of anything bad to say about
cuomo
it's weird it's like it sucked all of
that over to him
how does one explain de blasio's
behavior well he's dancing
while there was a madman on a full-on
rampage through new york city
beating people with a wooden pole he
uh injured 10 people knocked him out he
was mentally ill so who's in charge of
the mentally ill
well his dance partner is she got
something like 800 million
to oversee the mentally ill that it's
only gotten worse in new york city
people are
leaving because the streets are unsafe
so the fact that i mean i think she's
getting away with something
by being married to him and the other
thing too is when we see people
suffering he sees opportunity he's
always looked at
upheaval as a road to progressive ideals
like
when you see pain he sees disruption so
none of this stuff is bothering him
which is why he could just keep on
dancing
while everybody's weeping
dana the coveted vaccine uh the
storyline has been
where's the federal plan but in governor
cuomo's
case uh he's blaming hospitals and what
about that story
so yeah so where does the buck stop
right so governors love to talk about
state sovereignty
and they should we need a federal state
system and the states are the ones that
are responsible for carrying out
disaster aid
for example when fema gives grants it
goes to the governor the governor then
makes the
decisions on where that aid is going to
go i think that this is a great example
of not just in new york but also in dc
today where 64
of the available appointments were
unfilled for vaccine distribution today
i believe that the free market needs to
get a handle on this the private sector
needs to get involved
do you think for one second if any of
these private companies were in charge
of this that this would have happened
no so some sort of public-private
partnership needs to happen asap so that
people can get vaccinated as quickly as
possible so we can get people back to
work in school
and enjoying life again yeah clearly
there's an issue one
yeah it's a big issue you know it to me
though it's not about local officials to
me it's the
lack of federal leadership that says
here's a strategy here's how we want it
done
and if you're a local official you're
really saying we don't have the money
to put in place a plan so you see the
governor in new york
pointing to the hospitals the hospitals
are saying hey we're at capacity we have
so many issues to deal with why are you
picking on us
but again it's just like testing trump
didn't want testing said it made him
look bad hurt his election chances
and we never got a real regime for how
it should be best done in this country
we still suffer from that
jesse last word well de blasio has no
shame and he has no rhythm
and instead of writing a book about
covid maybe cuomo should have been
writing a vaccine distribution plan
juan it is the federal government's job
to get people the shots
and it's the governor's job to get the
shots in people's arms
all of the counties in the state of new
york have submitted their vaccination
plans to the governor
and the governor has still not signed
off on them the governor froze
the governor choked and now is choking
off
all of these vaccines to get them out to
these counties
right now there should be a vaccination
spot in every single zip code
in this state they should have brought
up the guard they should have brought up
the medical reserve they should have had
volunteers out here they keep saying
this is war
so act like it's war this should be done
24
7 not just monday through friday
nine to five down in the sunshine state
desantis
you can drive up roll your window down
to a mobile site
pull your shirt up and they'll stick you
right in the arm why can't they do that
here
instead they're putting all their
resources into locking up pub
owners i bet you the pub owner could
come up with a better idea to get people
shot right they're good with shots there
you go